you're in your 40s you're not married
you have no kids why can you judge her
but people cannot judge you that was a
question I was asked I think it's a very
good question for you to respond to I
think that's a I get that question all
the time are you basically saying that
men and women are the same I think it
takes uh a while it takes years for a
man to mature to reach his status you
know they say that men are success
objects and women are Beauty objects men
are judged on their resources their
money their age their income their game
their personality there's a whole host
of things that men are judged on okay
women eighty percent of the chart is
their beauty news flash guys like pretty
women all right you're a model
congratulations like you wouldn't be
modeling if guys found you unattractive